le tribunal de mâcon c'est un beau
palais du xviiie siècle
mais lorsque l'on regarde derrière la
façade on se rend vite compte que les
services judiciaires n'ont pas assez de
place pour travailler correctement alors
le contentieux effectivement et
volumineux vous le voyez les boîtes
d'archivés s'entassent et le tribunal
surtout étaient les trois en termes de
bureaux et des espaces de réunion et de
salles de travail qui permettrait
effectivement d'avoir des espaces de
convivialité puis de travail sous forme
de salles de réunion les lieux sont
tellement exigu que certains services
sont logés ailleurs dans la ville
une situation que la municipalité de
mâcon souhait de voir changer en
construisant un bâtiment et en
réhabilitant l'ancienne maison d'arrêt
c'est une opération qui va tourner
autour de 4 millions 4,5 millions
d'euros une opération importante et une
fois que le bâtiment sera construit par
la ville de mâcon qui sera louée remise
à la justice
donc le ministère de la justice fera une
opération financière pour 1 acceptable
puisqu'elle ne paiera pas plus de loyer
à la ville de mâcon qu'elles ne payent à
l'heure actuelle pour louer différents
bâtiments pour ses services à
l'extérieur du palais de justice
exceptionnellement nous avons pu
pénétrer dans cet ancien enceintes
pénitentiaires
c'est par une petite porte on y accède
les lieux sont abandonnés depuis 1991
sans électricité ni chauffage
le bâtiment construit dans les années
1815 et en souffrance entre les grilles
et les escaliers 3 on découvre cependant
quelques pièces atypiques comme cette
chapelle voué à disparaître de ce que
l'on entend mais tout reste à faire
les plans sont encore en cours il ya des
discussions qui ont démarré
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle la logique
voudrait que tout disparaisse
certains seront un peu triste de la
disparition de ce site historique
mais l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est de
faire un projet qui tienne la route
qu'ils soient rationnelle à terme une
centaine de personnes travailleront ici
la communauté judiciaire mâconnaise
cela cette création à la fois va marquer
l'importance des institutions
judiciaires sur mâcon et va les rendre
beaucoup plus visible et puis évidemment
c'est un bel outil de travail sans doute
qui nous attend qui va faciliter les
relations entre les avocats et les
juridictions et j'espère aussi pour le
plus grand bénéfice des justiciables
les premiers coups de pioche sont
attendus cette année ou en 2010 9